at Gabby's barbers they don't just cut
hair they also do international money
transfer sending money winning from here
in South London all around the world I
just sent wanted to gain our saw in
Liberia which is a girl your family
loved in one there you need to support
but to me everywhere in the aura is a
big business so big more than five
hundred billion pounds who sent last
year and from 2020 that'll be one of the
many financial services available on
face book which today announced its
latest earth-shattering mission to
become as big in banking as it is in
social media today the planet has about
1.7 billion people who are unbanked and
an equal number who are under banked and
yet of that number about a billion of
them have a mobile phone so when you
start connecting the dots with digital
assets crypto currencies blockchain this
new project has an opportunity to
improve Financial Inclusion around the
world Facebook service will allow you to
send money instantly and cheaply on
whatsapp or Facebook not in pounds but
in its new currency Libre it's got the
backing of big names like uber Vodafone
MasterCard and Visa he'll be backing it
with their own assets giving it less
volatility than digital currencies like
Bitcoin factored in Facebook's massive
audience and Libre could make even the
biggest financial institutions look tiny
let alone startups striving to compete
the truth is most remittances aren't
simply placed like this anymore
because they're already apt to do this
sort of thing cheaply and easily like as
Demong or transfer wise or revolute so
what Facebook is offering isn't actually
very new except for one crucial fact
it's on Facebook which leaves an
important question what's in this for
Facebook the answer could be very
familiar Facebook's business model it's
predicated around data and using data
for better ad targeting so you know the
promise here is the holy grail of
advertising if you can connect social
data the social context of what people
want what they want to purchase their
needs and aspirations with their
financial data so what they're actually
purchasing what they might be saving for
this is the holy grail for advertising
so the question is can can Facebook
resist that temptation the governor of
the Bank of England says he's keeping an
open mind on Libre he's probably also
keeping a close watch
now Facebook's into finance things could
get very interesting well a mantle Sky
News